[Music]
soing up
[Applause]
[Music]
down what you say about his company is
what you say
ever since I was a child people said my
family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could
ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Harry I want you to join your
brother's in the ring yes sir I love
that now we all know Carrie's my
favorite then Kev then David then Mike
but the rankings can always change what
do you want in life Kevin B Eric more
ribs I want to be with my
family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your
brothers har and
[Music]
David together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that will pass down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're a
lot I love your family
Kevin you going to be an uncle yes sir
oh man that makes me so happy I talk to
you about something M Dad's too tough on
us you got to say something maybe that's
what your brothers are you feel that you
feel that that's
pressure you're pushing too hard I'm
fine giid seriously I'm just
sick I'm scared man it all my out of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I needed to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal what we are
through I told you to look out for him I
just love being out there with you guys
the only thing that matters to me the
will forever be the greatest family in
the history of
[Applause]
[Music]
wrest